cuantas pulgadas hay en cuatro y media
yardas déjame poner aquí abajo esto
cuatro cuatro y media yardas ya vas
bueno como vamos a realizar una
conversión este 4 que está aquí como
entero va a ser un poco incómodo es
decir cuando estamos haciendo
conversiones es un poco difícil trabajar
con números mixtos así que déjame
primero convertir 4 y un medio a una
fracción impropia lo voy a hacer de este
lado si tenemos 4 y un medio para
pasarlo a una fracción impropia debemos
poner este mismo denominador o sea
tenemos que poner aquí abajo 2 y ahora
debemos pasar estos 4 estos 4 enteros a
fracciones a medios bueno pues este 4
déjame hacerlo con otro color este 4 es
lo mismo que 8 medios no voy a poner más
para arriba 8 medios ya eso tenemos que
sumarle este medio de acá 8 medios más
un medio de esta forma 4 con un medio es
lo mismo que 9 medios esta es la forma
elaborada de hacerlo si quieres hacerlo
de manera rápida
simplemente multiplicamos
4 x 2 que es ocho y sumamos 1 que es 9
bueno entonces sabemos que cuatro y
media yardas son nueve entre dos entre
dos yardas yardas y ahora sí podemos
realizar la conversión
queremos pasar yardas a pulgadas
podríamos hacerlo de golpe pero déjame
hacerlo paso a paso primero vamos a
pasar de yardas a pies y luego de pies
vamos a pasar a pulgadas entonces déjame
empezar pasando yardas a pies para pasar
yardas a pies tenemos que recordar que
en cada yarda hay tres pies déjame
escribirlo por aquí aquí voy a
multiplicar por tres pies tres pies
y tenemos que dividir entre yarda /
yarda entonces hay tres pies en cada si
quieres aquí le podemos poner un 1 en
cada yarda entonces lo ponemos así lo
ponemos con yardas abajo porque al final
nos gustaría obtener como unidades pies
entonces arriba va 3 pies y abajo va una
yarda para que yardas se cancele con
yarda y nos queden pies pero otra forma
de pensar lo es por tamaño si sabemos
que hay un 3 conviene multiplicar o
dividir
bueno pues yardas es una unidad más
grande que pies de modo que si pasamos
yardas a pies debemos terminar con más
pies que yardas por esta forma por esta
razón si sabemos que hay un 3
involucrado hay que multiplicar por 3
para obtener un número más grande bueno
vamos a ver qué nos queda déjame hacerlo
poco a poco voy a poner 9 medios aquí al
principio nueve medios voy a multiplicar
por tres multiplicar por tres y ahora
veamos qué sucede con las unidades
las charlas las voy a poner aquí aquí
quedan yardas yardas y eso eso lo voy a
multiplicar por pies por yarda pies por
yarda pies
por yarda yarda bueno veamos qué sucede
esto es igual a esto es igual a 9 por 13
es 27 y hay que dividir entre 2 entonces
nos queda 27 medios 27 medios y en las
unidades yardas se cancela con yarda y
nos queda pies 27 medios 27 entre 2 pies
muy bien entonces con esto pasamos
yardas a pies y tiene sentido verdad
tiene sentido que hayamos obtenido 27
entre 2 pies porque eso es más que 9
medios o sea realmente al pasar de la
unidad grande a la pequeña aumentó la
cantidad de unidades que tenemos bueno
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es pasar esto
a pulgadas porque eso es lo que nos
estaban preguntando entonces déjame
poner estos 27 entre 2 pies aquí 27
entre 2
ok y ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
recordar cuántos pies o cuantas pulgadas
hay en cada pie y hay 12 pulgadas en
cada pie de verdad entonces ahora el
factor de conversión sería 2 y tenemos
que multiplicar por 12 y otra vez
multiplicamos por 12 para obtener una
mayor cantidad de pulgadas que de pies
entonces hay que multiplicar por 12 y
las unidades como serían bueno pues hay
12 pulgadas pulgadas
en cada pie voy a poner
en cada pie muy bien y las unidades
quedan bien verdad porque pies se va a
cancelar con pie y al final nos va a
quedar pulgadas déjame realizar las
operaciones esto de aquí sería igual a
27 entre 2 27 entre 2 multiplicado por
12 por 12 x pies
ya ya deberías saltarme al paso final
verdad pero mejor vamos poco a poco x 10
x pulgadas pulgadas
en cada pie por pie bueno aquí pie se
cancela con pies de modo que las
unidades quedan pulgadas y esto es igual
a esto es igual a 27 por 12 27 por 12
dividido entre dos pulgadas pulgadas
y esto lo podemos simplificar verdad
podemos hacer 27 por 12 y dividir entre
2 o mejor aún podemos hacer primero 12
entre dos y luego multiplicar por 27
para que sea un poco más sencillo
realizar las operaciones 12 entre 12 6 y
tenemos que hacer 27 por 6 vamos a ver
cuánto da eso 27 por 6 6 por 7 42
llevamos 4 6 por 2 es 12 y 4 que
llevamos 16 es 162 de modo que nos queda
nos queda que cuatro y media yardas es
igual a 162 162 pulgadas pulgadas y otra
vez todo esto tiene mucho sentido porque
empezamos con una cierta cantidad de
yardas al pasarla a pies aumentó y al
pasarla a pulgadas aumentó todavía más
obtuvimos muchísimas pulgadas